in this video we are going to see that
the quran contains a wealth of
information about the world of the
occult
our analysis will focus on the second
chapter of the quran
known as surah al-baqarah in particular
verses 101-102
we will analyze these verses from the
perspective of history and archaeology
the verses begin by saying and when a
messenger from allah
came to them confirming that which was
with them the children of israel
a party of those who had been given the
scripture
through the scripture of allah behind
their backs as if they did not know
what it contained and they followed
instead what the devils had recited
during the reign of solomon the
classical muslim exegetes
ibn kethir and tabari both explained
that the quran here is referring to a
faction of jews
at the time of muhammad peace be upon
him who rejected him
despite knowing he was a messenger the
quran rebukes them
for not acting upon this knowledge of
his prophethood
which is contained in their very own
scriptures
they are accused of abandoning their
scriptures and instead
resorting to practicing the magic of
their ancestors from the time of solomon
there are a number of amazing insights
to note here
firstly we can see that the quran makes
an important distinction
between scripture and the works of
devils namely that of magic
the quran states that a party of jews
abandoned allah's words
and turned to the magic of devils
implying that their scriptures are free
of magic
if we compare the old testament with
rabbinic writings
we find that this is the case the old
testament states
you shall not permit a sorceress to live
mediums and necromancers shall surely be
put to death
let no one be found among you who
interprets omens
we can see that the old testament has a
zero tolerance approach to all forms of
magic
by comparison rabbinic texts such as the
talmud are full of occult teachings
rabbi wrote i see in the
babylonian talmud
many things which were permitted from
the realm of fortune telling
incantations and witchcraft these are
innumerable
here are just some examples of occultism
in the talmud
if one wishes to see demons let him take
the afterbirth of a black
shikat let him roast it in fire and
grind it to powder
and then let him put some into his eye
what is an approved amulet one that has
healed once
a second time and a third time
the course of the constellations and the
zodiac has influence as a natural law
upon the world
and everything depends upon it longevity
children and finances
it's clear that the talmud promotes a
whole host of occult practices
including sorcery amulets and astrology
we've seen that these are all practices
that the old testament deems punishable
by death
scripture and rabbinic writings are
completely at odds
when it comes to the permissibility of
magic just as the quran states
another quranic insight is the fact that
the verse is addressing a group of jews
who are contemporary to the prophet
muhammad peace be upon him
and making the claim that they were
following the magic of devils from the
time of solomon
given that solomon is from the 10th
century bce
and the quran was revealed in the 7th
century ce
this points to a continuous magic
tradition of at least one and a half
thousand years
if this really is the case then we would
expect jewish practitioners
to have mastered these dark arts over
such a long period of time
this is exactly what we find in the
world of magic
for centuries jewish mythicism such as
kabbalah
and jewish numerology known as gematria
have been fundamental to occultism
to this day anyone who is serious about
the occult
must study these jewish systems as they
are considered foundational
yet another quranic insight can be found
in the linguistics of this verse
note the word recited devils are said to
recite
magic the use of spoken incantations
and evocations are in fact a major part
of magic
madame blavatsky was a highly
influential 19th century mystic
she explained that occultists throughout
history
have used symbols to convey meaning
because they feared the real-world
effects
of the spoken word the religious and
esoteric history of every nation
was embedded in symbols it was never
expressed in so many words
why because such or another vibration in
the air
is sure to awaken corresponding powers
union with which produces good or bad
results
the ancient egyptians held similar
beliefs about the power of the spoken
word
the commonly found phrases magic of
their mouths
and spells of their utterances show the
close relationship between speaking and
magic
the two were treated as more or less
equivalent
the ancient mesopotamians also believed
that incantations
had to be spoken in a certain way in
order for them to be effective
voice can harvest the power and
knowledge contained within a name
the incantation and names contained in
them had to be pronounced in a special
tone of voice
the word used to describe one speaking
in this manner lohushu
is even different from the regular verb
se and had a meaning similar to
utter murmur or chant
the next part of the verses state it was
not solomon who disbelieved
but the devils disbelieved teaching
people magic
here the quran defends the noble prophet
solomon clearing him of the false
accusations of magic
rabbis and jewish commentators
throughout history have claimed that
solomon was a master magician
for example the talmud claims that
solomon possessed a magical ring
that was the source of his ability to
control devils
the talmud narrates the following story
the demon asmodius said to solomon give
me your ring with god's name engraved on
it
and i will show you my strength solomon
gave him his ring
asmodius swallowed the ring and grew
until he placed
one wing in the heaven and one wing on
the earth
he threw solomon a distance of 400
parasangs
i.e over one thousand miles with solomon
deposed from the throne
as modius took his place while asmodius
was impersonating solomon
he demanded that solomon's mother engage
in sexual intercourse with him
once the jewish council heard this they
understood that this was an impostor
and not actually solomon they brought
solomon and gave him a ring on which the
name of god was carved
when solomon entered asmodius saw him
and fled
followers of judaism need to realize
that such rabbinic teachings
actually go against the old testament
which we've already seen
strictly prohibits all forms of magic
rabbis have therefore created
contradictions
within the religion itself the quran
clarifies
that a magical trinket was not the
source of solomon's power
rather allah himself was the source of
solomon's miraculous ability
to subjugate devils and control animals
solomon's abilities are no different to
the miracles that allah bestowed upon
other israelite prophets
such as moses we can see that the quran
resolves the confusion
that is present within judaism
the next part of the verses state
teaching people magic
and that which was revealed to the two
angels at babylon
here the quran makes the claim that
babylon was a major epicenter for magic
thanks to modern archaeological
discoveries we now know
that babylonians laid the foundation for
magical practices used all around the
world
for example astrology is one of the core
sciences in magic today
the babylonians were the first people to
apply myths to constellations
and describe the 12 signs of the zodiac
enuma anu enlil is a series of
babylonian tablets
that represent the oldest astrological
writings in the world
the conquest of asia by alexander the
great
exposed the greeks to babylonian culture
they took the babylonian system of
astrology developed it
and spread it all around the world
another claim being made here by the
quran
is that the magic of the jews at the
time of prophet muhammad
peace be upon him had its roots in
ancient babylon
a number of historical evidences both
textual
and archaeological support this claim
the talmud is a written compilation of
rabbinic discussions
that comprise the foundation of jewish
law two different versions of the talmud
were produced
the jerusalem talmud and the babylonian
talmud
with the former produced in the land of
israel and the latter in babylon
when contrasting the two scholars have
observed that the babylonian talmud
is comparatively full of references to
demons and magic
a perfect example that illustrates this
difference can be found in the old
testament book of ecclesiastes
i acquired male and female singers and a
harem as well
compare the babylonian and jerusalem
talmudic commentaries on this verse
here in babylonia they interpreted these
words in the following manner
male demons and female demons
in the land of israel they said that
these words are referring to carriages
this supports the quran's claims about
the babylonian roots of jewish magic
as those jews who were exiled to babylon
were exposed to
and influenced by its magical culture
we can see this influence reflected in
the content of the babylonian talmud
from an archaeological perspective the
earliest known examples of jewish
mystical texts
are babylonian incantation balls this
further supports the quran's claim
that jews first learnt magic at babylon
professor shawl shackhead wrote
the jewish aramaic balls also have the
earliest examples
of hecalot or jewish mystical texts
you also find named jewish rabbis and
demons
as well as information about jewish
legal practice
moreover the vast majority of
incantation balls that have been
excavated in the babylonian region
are written in jewish aramaic an essay
on magic balls states that
the largest number of known incantation
balls are written in jewish aramaic by
jewish scribes
mandaean bowls are the second most
numerous only then followed by balls in
syriac
a handful of balls in arabic and persian
are also known
this shows that babylonian jews were
heavily involved in magic
historians even go so far as to suggest
that they achieved a mastery of the dark
arts
professor joseph nave wrote magic may
have been considered to some extent
a jewish specialization
the next part of the verses state the
two angels at babylon
haroot and marut but they do not teach
anyone unless they say
we are a trial so do not disbelieve by
practicing magic
here the quran is making the claim that
two angels
haroot and marut descended at babylon
these angels are said to have been sent
by allah and given knowledge of magic
as a means of testing mankind is there
any historical evidence
for the existence of the angels haroot
or marut
there just happens to be some striking
parallels between the angel marut
and an entity known as marduk marduk was
an ancient mesopotamian deity
who was the chief god of the city of
babylon marduk is the name commonly
associated with the deity in modern
times
however it was actually pronounced
marutok in babylonian
scholars believe that this word is
derived from the sumerian
amarutu the quranic marut
may simply be an arabised version of the
babylonian marutok
and sumerian amarutu marduk
also happens to have been associated
with magic as far back as the old
babylonian period
during babylonian magic rituals priests
known as asipu
would impersonate marduk a tablet reads
the asipo is the image of amarutu
[Music]
marduk was glorified as the greatest of
exorcists
a tablet reads upon the utterance of
amarutu
exorcist among the gods
seal that calls upon marduk served as an
amulet
it states by the order of amarutu may he
who was provided with this seal be in
good health
marduk was also commonly invoked to ward
off demons
the urdug hull writings are a series of
16 tablets
consisting of incantations for
protection against evil demons
several of the tablets are in fact hymns
to marduk
for example by the invocation of marduk
ruler of babylon may whatever evil be
removed from the body of the man
may the evil otoku demon an evil aloo
demon stand aside
marduk was even called the magician of
the gods
note in the following inscription that
marduk is referred to by the name
asalouhi before the spell of assalohi
the magician of the gods the parallels
between marduk
and the angel marut go beyond their
names and magical associations
the supreme god aya was believed to be
the ultimate source of marduk's
knowledge
in the following babylonian text marduk
is said to consult af advice
may my father the great lord ayer show
you the right
and the master plan of ayah's wisdom he
marduk was searching
he was searching there for the supreme
word of aya's command
we can see that the relationship between
marduk and
ayah is similar to that of the angel
marut and allah
with marduk and marut both being
subservient
and receiving knowledge from the higher
authorities aya
and allah even the name of the city of
babylon
has connotations with the quranic angels
the word babylon
comes from the ancient mesopotamian
babilim which means
gate of the gods this could be a
reference to its importance as the site
where angels brought magic to mankind
hence it was seen as a kind of gateway
to receiving wisdom from above
there is in fact a creation myth known
as enuma elish
in which marduk is said to have
commanded the building of babylon
construct babylon whose building you
have requested let its brickwork be
fashioned
now you may be wondering how is it
possible that the angel marut
was transformed into the babylonian god
marduk
mankind has a tendency to defy mortals
this has been the norm throughout
history with heroes and people of great
importance being taken as objects of
worship
an obvious example is the christian
elevation of jesus from human messiah
to god incarnate with regards to marduk
historians acknowledge that his origins
are shrouded in mystery
the scholar daniel block wrote that the
ultimate origins of marduk remain a
mystery
the surviving historical records do
indicate that marduk
greatly grew in stature over time the
babylonian epic
enuma elish chronicles the rise of
marduk
from hero to king of the gods marduk is
even said to have taken on 50 names and
attributes
for us under whatever name he might be
called he is our god
so gather round and let us all call him
by all his fifty names
as professor marcum geller puts it it is
clear
that the principal divine authority
authenticating the power of incantations
was aya
god of wisdom whose role was primary one
of the innovations of odokhul
was the increased centrality of marduk
as the main god of healing
independent of ayah and no longer acting
as aya's representative
at least three tablets of a doghole
focused primarily
on marduk's role as the chief
protagonist which is a major departure
from his traditional role as aya's
assistant
what's incredible is that this
information about the angel marut
and its links to babylon and magic is
unique to the quran
it's not mentioned anywhere in the bible
or rabbinic texts
such as the talmud now the god marduk is
mentioned once in the bible
however very little information is
provided and it has no association with
magic
or angels the final part of the verses
state
and yet they learn from them that by
which they cause separation between a
man
and his wife and the people learn what
harms them
and does not benefit them but their
children of israel certainly knew
that whoever purchased the magic would
not having here after any share
and wretched is that for which they sold
themselves if they only knew
here the quran tells us that the angels
brought a new type of knowledge
something very powerful that can cause a
husband and wife to separate
now the quran does not go into detail
about the exact nature of the magic that
descended
however notice the mention of the word
purchased the quran could be alluding
to the transactional nature of
interactions between magicians and jinn
indeed a common thread that runs through
all magic traditions
is the concept of working with spiritual
entities in order to obtain some worldly
benefit or cause harm to others
the magician does something for a gin
such as praising it or offering a
sacrifice
and in return the jinn provides a
service for the magician
also note the mention of the
consequences of engaging in magic
the quran issues the severe warning that
it is at the cost of one's hereafter
the magician quite literally has to sell
their soul
in order for the jinn to comply their
reality
is that in order to reach the higher
levels a magician must commit the
greatest of evils
which is demonstrated in their
philosophy and morality
magicians refer to the systems they use
as the left-hand path
conventional religion is referred to as
the right-hand path
note what this magician has to say about
islam and the right-hand path
in a few terms what do you mean by the
left-hand path
for semantic purposes we use the phrase
right-hand path
to define those religions or spiritual
practices
that attempt to submit
to a greater force a god a universal
principle
that unites humanity together
so you put me in the buddhists and the
hindus in the muslims everybody else
all kind of in one category over here
and
the right-hand path would consist of in
religions you'd be familiar with
islam is the most radical right-hand
path system the very word means
submission
islam is the most radical right-hand
path system the very word means
submission
this distinction between the left and
right hand paths is a very old one
that has been recorded as far back as
ancient india
the left-hand path is based on two main
principles
firstly self-deification whereas the
right-hand path
seeks dependence on god followers of the
left-hand path seek to become god-like
the conventional acts of disbelief that
magicians take part in
such as calling upon idols and
worshiping the jinn are bad enough
but the left hand path takes things to
an extreme it reaches new heights of
blasphemy
with a magician seeking godhood in
themselves
the second principle of the left-hand
path is challenging normative
conventions of morality
there is a reversal of moral categories
evil becomes good impure becomes pure
darkness becomes light followers at the
left-hand path
intentionally break all taboos in order
to reconstitute themselves as a divine
being
operating outside the laws and
restrictions of man
for example many religions place
prohibitions on menstruating women
they are forbidden from taking part in
certain acts of worship and married
women refrain from sexual intimacy
the follower of the left-hand path
however will purposely seek to violate
all of these prohibitions now we can
understand
why the quran is so severe in its
condemnation of magic
it is a path that leads the greatest of
evils on earth
and ultimately the eternal hell fire and
hereafter
in conclusion we've seen that these
short verses of the quran
are filled with tremendous insights into
different areas of the world of the
occult
including the jews of babylon the
ancient origins of magic
and the interaction between jin and
magicians
to learn more about the world of the
occult from an islamic perspective
please download your free copy of the
book the forbidden prophecies
at the link below